the era of clocking in on your couch
could be over America's top executives
are running out of patience for
employees who refuse to return to the
office Amazon CEO Andy jasse delivering
a blunt message to workers who can't
muster at least three days a week on
site telling them quote if you can't
disagree and commit it's probably not
going to work out for you at Amazon
Goldman Sachs wants employees in the
office a full five days a week they're
also terminating the company's summer
Friday's policy which lets people skip
out early and workers better be careful
New York Times workers are trying to
stop management from monitoring badge
swipes to see if they're following the
paper's return to office mandate all
right Jesse one study found that workers
who preferred working from home uh
produce substantially less productive
work 27% less productive work than they
did when they were at the office so is
it any surprise the big time CEOs want
some back if I was a big time CEO I'm
big time I'm not a CEO but if I if I was
running things I would absolutely want
100% of the office
back if you're living in the suburbs and
you're working remotely who are you
seeing all day you're seeing your wife
maybe you're seeing your child but
that's it when I'm commuting in I'm not
saying they're not stimulating but if
you're just sitting in your living room
or your home office and you're just
seeing your family all day maybe your
mother-in-law you're you're not
absorbing life you're not absorbing the
environment you're not absorbing the
state or the city that you live in or
the e or the economy that you're
supposed to be producing for when you're
commuting you're talking to the Coffee
Guy the paper guy the train conductor
other commuters you're seeing what it's
like coming through Midtown Manhattan
and J it's gotten a lot worse if I lived
all the way out in the suburbs and never
came in I wouldn't know how bad the city
is I mean you see tent cities here you
see Junkies you
seeig
prices awesome you know what sounds
great am I making the wrong Point yes
yes you are look you know what Charlie
uh the Amazon employees are claiming the
reason they don't want go want to go
back to work full time is because of the
carbon footprint you buy that one uh
yeah no not all although I do think it's
kind of funny that like meta and Amazon
are calling people back even though
they've they've made a fortune off of
telecommuting or delivering things at
home so that people don't ever have to
leave the house um the Goldman Sachs
thing I'm a little bit worried about
because I think that's actually a play
to try to shore up like we like when you
look at the floors commercial real
estate in New York I mean it's just
empty floors after empty floors I think
they're just trying to protect their
investment they want their money's worth
yeah they want to get people back in but
anybody who thinks that they don't have
to come to work so you you know you walk
up and down uh 6th Avenue and look down
and you see the hotels where they're
putting all the illegal aliens and the
you outside there's like 500 Vespas
parked out and they're all out there
with their phones looking for for work
so you know if you don't come back to
work they've already got like a whole
Army of people ready to come step in and
pick up the loose ends you know Richard
um I think it's 15% of the workforce is
willing to take a pay cut to uh to keep
their remote job uh whatever happened to
passion and Merit and getting to the top
and and one of the things that Jesse
didn't mention is having your boss see
how good you are at what you do that's
why I'm sitting here right now right um
but no in Real Talk look I'm a big
believer in work life balance and I'm
also a big believer in office
flexibility and and I do think that as
we transition back to coming back to the
office we need to reframe the
conversation a little bit because I felt
like during the work from home era at
least for me I got I did more work right
like I instead of like clocking out
instead of leaving at 5:00 at 8:00 I was
at home like let me just continue
working so I think if you reframe it as
we're 9 to 5 so 501 feel free to leave
whereas then if you're working from home
and you're working on a project your
boss would be more likely to send you a
7:00 email so I think when bosses talk
about it the threatening people probably
not how you get there I think you talk
about the benefits of like listen at 5
o'clock feel free to leave and don't
answer my emails but if you're going to
work from home and I send you an 8:00
email you're going to have to answer
that I think that's the frame that it
needs to live in as a message instead of
scaring them back to work that's not
really going to work you know Katie one
of the things that Charlie said that is
so true is that the the real estate in
Manhattan I mean all of these Office
Buildings I don't know what's going to
happen in the next few years uh but the
the whole idea of returning back to work
might even get us back to a better
footing because then employees will
demand safer streets they they would
demand that the government take take
care of them and make sure that they are
protected I mean it's almost as though
people first of all I think everybody
looks like a slob these days true people
don't care anymore and it just kind of
permeates everything that we do well not
everyone can be as Fabulous As you well
that's not what on a daily basis but um
yeah I mean these companies are paying
tens of thousands of dollars per month
for this rental space that their workers
are not utilizing so they are trying to
justify that cost they're locked into
these long-term leases that are taking
up a lot of money on their balance
sheets but I actually agree with Richard
I think that it depends on the job it
depends on the person there are ways
that you can hold people accountable if
they're not producing uh from home but
there's I was I brought this up last
time uh I know a girl who is an Amazon
software engineer and she goes to the
office and it's very distracting for her
because they have these open office
spaces and she codes a lot more when
she's in her space doing work what about
office
romance
without the office you don't want to go
there you have no office that's the
third I'll stop your head I don't think
we need families in this country we need
child I'm not get trouble I one more
real quick the fastest is up next
because yes he doesn't need to talk hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now